Elon and Zuck beefin in the virtual
world and the physical world what do you
think about
uh Elon Sue and Zuck for Threads I don't
think it's going to go through no yeah
how can you 've won what grounds can you
sue
I think he has the source code open
for Twitter I think Elon made the made
it open source and just like kind of
like put the source code out there and I
think that is going to cause a lot of
problems if it becomes if it goes to
litigation because they can say oh did
you hire ex-twitter employees yes but
they I don't think they breach contracts
because I think they were terminated for
a long enough time they they would have
to prove that they like violated some
type of like non-compete which I don't
think they can do and then on top of
that it's all open source code so they
can just look at it and be like yeah you
got access to it yeah I don't know the
threatens they hired all of them as
consultants I think that gets around the
contracts because they're not employees
yeah and you fired them so if you fire
you're not going to competitor unless
you gave me a crazy Severance I don't
think there's I think I just do whatever
I want yeah fired unceremoniously it
seemed like they just woke up to an
email they were fired and I can't go
work for a competitor that seems crazy
has anybody used it no I've posted one
thing on it yeah the major part of the
lawsuit is that uh meta recruited
several former Twitter employees who
possess and even currently have access
to Twitter's Trade Secrets enough their
confidential information yeah I just I
like these Tech lawsuits I just don't
think go through there's so many Twitter
knockoffs like there's Mastodon there's
blue sky like what's the Trump one yeah
there's so many that have basically
copied it like I mean blue skies
literally created by Jack Dorsey that is
a stripped down version of Twitter so
what is the end game here like is Elon
just trying to what is it called uh
stir up Waters to catch fish is he just
using this as an opportunity to promote
Twitter
like engaging in the beef and then
hopefully you know that will take people
back over to Twitter where he's tweeting
about it
you know like all of his criticism was
Zuckerberg come from Twitter so he's
maybe driving traffic over to Twitter
but I don't know I I just I don't think
I think he's [__] up homie he's
[__] up yeah you think yeah yes I
couldn't believe he actually bought
Twitter I'll say that forever I thought
that was just publicity we're getting
whatever I'm gonna pull out of the deal
at the last second when it happened I
was like what is your end game here and
Twitter just seems worse one cool thing
is you can upload a whole video for
however long it don't matter but then
like do you see remember that day where
you could only read x amount of tweets
and they just stopped letting you
retweets no I'm not a loser
I'm not did they really tell you you
reached your limit yeah yeah when it was
like pay for verification yeah they're
just trying to get everybody to pay the
eight dollars I ain't gonna do it yeah
so is it still the way
um yeah I think they raised the
threshold but still at a certain point
you're gonna need to get which I haven't
hit now why are they going to this pay
model I don't I they're going away from
ad revenue and just trying to make it
subscription like and make all the money
on a subscription side and so that's the
issue because no one wants to pay for
something that they were using for free
yeah like
you don't think about this before you
spend 44 billion on something and like
so many celebrities are fine with not
having their blue check there they don't
give a [__] I'm curious do you have your
blue check I don't think so it's a [__]
and so it's like he [__] up
I don't know it might be too soon to say
like it is interesting to me that so
many other like like channels have taken
some of the things that Twitter's done
like paying for verification through
Instagram I think Facebook has it as
well now yeah the NFL stole [__] from
the XFL that only the XFL a good league
right I mean don't make XFL a good idea
yeah yeah but I don't know if it's too
soon I feel like it's too soon to say
it's uh I'm just looking what is this
end goal that's what I'm trying to say
like he's he's really active right now
I don't think that he's really active
Because he believes he's going to win
this lawsuit against threads I don't
think threads is unique enough that
people will totally transition and go
over there I think it's like fun for
people right now because they feel like
they get a bunch of new followers and
they'll be like one of the few people
that are on this space but I don't know
if it has anything compelling enough to
like go there and digest content you
know like Tick Tock is undeniably
entertaining yeah like you went to it
and you're like wow this is better than
all the other apps yeah like just
scrolling now the Instagram is kind of
caught up with reels and YouTube with
shorts but when it was just Tick Tock
that had that feature where it's like
you don't even need to follow anybody we
know what you like my wife is still so
addicted nuts it's like if you had like
30 minutes you and your wife
and you just decide to scroll Tick Tock
you laugh together yeah you might cry to
video it's like I can't believe I'm
making this argument for tick tock it
could be [__] reels it could be
shorts whatever but this type of
entertainment yeah you get like a lot of
feelings out of a 30-minute thing that's
why I had to say reels and I had to say
China
I [__] felt myself all I'm trying to
say is I don't see myself going on
threads for breaking news I don't see I
think it's exciting and it was really
easy conversion because you do it all
through Instagram pretty much yeah like
you're like do you want to follow
everybody you already follow yeah not
only that the people that have huge
audiences on Instagram automatically get
this huge audience on thread so if it
does blow up and take over Twitter then
boom I've got a whole lot how is that
because I'm trying to figure out how
Zuckerberg thinks he can get people to
threads over Twitter
it's super easy you get to bring
yourself it's really convenient my issue
with those like the people that are like
Twitter smart people Instagram is like
pretty people you know what I mean like
the biggest pages on Instagram are like
aggregate Pages where it's like people
just post a ton of different content
like Instagram models and I don't know
if people want to hear what they have to
tweet no no I mean so you're trying to
bank on pulling Twitter levers over to
threads to then get like smart people on
threads and then pretty people on
Instagram and then you take over the
whole thing the only chance I have is
that Twitter goes under
and then there's an alternative that
exists where all your followers already
are right that works and it's like
having all Apple products where it's
just like it's synced up yeah are you
going to get journalists over the
threads that's like the big I think it's
easy copy and paste I think you'll get
all the same articles there and it will
be a literal mirror to Twitter the
question is are they going to
reconfigure the algorithm so you enjoy
what you're scrolling on more and I
think whoever that's the way I think
they could see it winning is go we're
not going to give you what you follow
we're going to give you what you enjoy
that's what it's currently doing so they
are tick tockifying it yeah if it's
doing that too but Twitter's doing that
too so whichever algo is better more
enjoyable will win but Instagram has an
opportunity to completely tick-tockify
threads and I wonder if that's no I
don't think it's more difficult who
knows I think if they find a way to just
integrate it with Instagram where you
don't have to use a separate app like
just have like a swipe where it's like I
want to use threads it's like a
different window because like so many
people would
um tweet something and then copy their
tweet and then post it on Instagram now
people just do that and also take your
thread and post it to your IG story yeah
yeah like yeah if you have complete
Synergy then they might be able to get
it popping yeah this go on off this app
and then open another app is a huge
barrier yeah I think yeah yeah I have
the IG story thing so like now if you
see a thread in there and you click on
that thread it takes you right to the
smart yeah okay so that kind of synergy
is is and that's seamlessness like you
were saying that's what Apple does so
well it's like everything is just your
[__] watch is connected to your TVs
connected to your computer your phone
yeah that's feel rushed though the
threads thing yeah in one way like it's
it feels kind of like a [__] okay and
it's like I'm like why wouldn't you wait
till the product is like great before
you put it out you think he's trying to
capitalize on the uh the beef the we're
gonna fight thing I think it's a little
bit of that but I also think there's a
lot of other Twitter competitors popping
up like there's one it's called spill
that like I've recently got on and it's
more targeted for you know
black urban community but that's the fun
one it popped so quick and I think they
saw I was like oh [__] we need to get up
gotta get on this before interesting
yeah it might have something to do with
it yeah yeah maybe they sense Chum in
the waters with Twitter it's getting
weak I thought Elon knew Zuckerberg was
going to launch threads and that's why
he started this whole we need to fight
beef [__] oh
tell you this was coming that's good
yeah I assume he got ahead of it once he
heard about threads and he hasn't heard
before yeah exactly oh that's a great
take I want to see that fight though
yeah I would have loved to see that yeah
brutalizing him son yeah you know it's
like six four or something he's like a
big [__] walrus looking guy and Mark
is what five eight yeah maybe like his
Jujitsu is not good enough where you can
mitigate that type of weight difference
I don't think elon's like working out
working out I think he's gonna lay off
just doing no zombie a big Zuckerberg is
[__] working out do you think he goes
down workout [__] that y'all did 1200 oh
the Murph yeah Zuckerberg he's getting
after it yeah
but I'll take a small guy 12 years older
though
elon's 52 Zuckerberg is 39. yeah yeah so
maybe he just gets exhausted yeah I mean
it's really interesting what Zuckerberg
did it's he started doing Jujitsu and
like integrated himself into MMA and
then use that as clout for people to
think that he was cooler than the
painted white face guy that is a robot
when he talks to Congress yeah yeah and
it [__] worked it [__] worked now
he's talking [__] on him on uh it
spreads talking [__] on Instagram saying
yo let's fight let's do Jiu Jitsu
whatever like he he he jumps on the wave
of MMA and the wave of MMA has so much I
guess masculine clout that it
de-nurtified him yeah he is cooler he's
objectively he's looking cool he just
physically he's doing cooler things
unbelievable
yeah he bombed on that metaverse [__]
but he's looking cooler too because it's
like 100 now like you out here oh yeah
how much of all this is also just like
yo metas in the [__] tank right now
let's lift evaluation by making me look
better I can't make meta any better
right now but I can make me look better
100 things company I feel like from the
name change is that now that they have
threads the fact it's not associated
directly with Facebook I actually think
gives threads a better chance like
Facebook I feel like is such an
Antiquated name the idea of like a young
person using a Facebook product feels
weird to them yeah so even just having a
be meta like threads by meta or whatever
makes it a little better and this is the
first product I feel like they launched
since changing the name hmm so in that
regard I'm like that is one benefit of
just changing the name even if the
product like the metaverse didn't work
just having the name meta I think is
better than Facebook interesting and you
can post videos and stuff on threads
right yeah yeah I think so so
essentially it's gonna be
a better version of Facebook
yeah it's like Facebook for young people
exactly so you replace Facebook or not
even replace you let the old people stay
over there on Facebook and the young
people start to adopt the Reds if they
want to and uh it's really like do black
people do it that's that's what's going
to come down to yeah if black people go
on threads and it pops the [__] off and
it's fun like black Twitter is fun then
I think people will go if they don't
there's no [__] chance I think
they're angling for younger people I
think that's the goal but they've got to
get the black Twitter going like I
haven't forgotten the name spill and I'm
like I need to go see what's up over
there yeah it feels kind of cool there's
just not enough people yet and so that's
why I think threads will probably win
because it's just so easy you need the
numbers bro and they've really made it
easy to sign up it's like Apple pay yeah
you know how like the most annoying
thing is typing in your [__]
information when you're about to buy
something online your name your [__]
email your all these credit card all
these things and then Apple pay came in
and it was just like tap once done I'll
buy anything now yeah there's no time
for me to think about my purchase yeah
so they're so good at that you know when
you get a code sent to you texted you
and then it just Auto populates oh yeah
I mean Apple's so good at all that get
rid of every barrier to entry possible
yeah yeah it's insane help me spend yeah
do you want to see the two of them fight
no I don't care I would I'm not watching
I would watch it yeah yeah I would watch
the [__] of it but I don't think it's
good for like America why like two
billionaires like two of the biggest
like technocrats that are like rule in
the country if you've seen that movie
it's exactly what they would do like I
just don't think it's like a good Global
look I don't know to me it feels like
it's just end of the Empire feels like a
falling Empire
it does have that feeling to me I think
they just start like the new
um
Logan Paul Jake Paul Fight League
amongst billionaires now it's like other
billionaires gonna want to get in now to
be like nah I'm the toughest building
there yeah it'll be fire I think the
best way to prove toughness of
billionaires is like to keep America on
course like the corporations around the
country and that's good and bad but as
soon as they're less thinking about
running the country more think about
like [__] up other billionaires
within the same country then I'm like oh
that's bad for the country yeah that's a
good point it is entertaining as [__]
like I'm gonna watch it I'm here for
entertainment babe
not a long time
yeah what did these Romans do that's
that's what I'm saying it feels circuses
from like but if the Romans had the
empires in the Gladiator ring or the
Emperors and the Gladiator you'd be like
what do you think and we don't have the
only billionaires like there's gonna be
other people getting into that you know
who one less Indian billionaire but I
mean
oh Pakistan
like once once they get in that now it's
going to be on some country [__] now we
rooting for Zuck if he's going against
the [__] Chinese billionaire yeah
that's fire that's kind of cool I don't
think the Chinese building like they're
gonna be allowed to go in this league
yeah China specifically I think China's
gonna be like you could do that another
one y'all could disappear we have no
problem do we want Elon Musk spending 14
hours a week training or 14 hours a week
solving the problems that will hopefully
continue the great legacy of the United
States of America I'd rather him train
than spend 14 hours a week on Twitter
but that's not what I I understand but I
mean he's already wasting his time doing
[__] that's not helping out the world so
it's like whatever if it takes them off
Twitter because he's kind of annoying on
Twitter so hey I'd rather you fight them
be on Twitter I have not 180 in a person
this hard in quite a while I mean I was
all Elon everything yeah and now I'm
like that's what I'm saying like shut up
for a little bit maybe I can go back to
liking you again please shut the [__] up
he just tweeted every once in a while
some like smug [__] it was funny it was
hilarious just too much too much you
know if he could fight if he's [__]
people up and then still sending Rockets
let's do it remember what Jimmy Jimmy
Ted Cruz played basketball and it was
like [__] three to four and they just
had to cancel the match no I'm not gay
I've never seen that okay
I've never seen that I didn't even know
what do you mean it was three to four it
was like a horrible game
I I think they called the game because
it took too long I could be wrong but
either way it was just pathetic it's
like y'all aren't athletes why are we
watching this yeah this would be the
same thing maybe the same thing it would
not maybe not for Zuckerberg as much
because he's clearly in shape but for
like someone gets head trauma some of
this [__] thinks of things that would
be hilarious yeah they're fighting each
other I'm like that's a very real
possibility show us how much you care
about UFC fighters I like those guys
[__] their heads up yeah right the Smart
Ones I mean if you build a multi-billion
dollar company I'm gonna be more
concerned about your brand yeah the
country isn't in their hands yeah you
know
in the country then I'd be like yo you
guys gotta chill keep doing country
stuff yeah but the corporations Run
America so I'm like keep keep doing that
yeah I don't want your focus on this
fight I'll be honest I mean I don't I
don't really think they're gonna fight
like I think it's just publicity and I
think it's good for both of them yeah
but uh I don't really think that they're
gonna fight there's no way it does keep
twittering because I think Elon neither
maybe he needs a w right now maybe
let me just focus on the cars man like
that's the other thing
you know how do all great Empires die
and spreading themselves too thin and
maybe that's what elon's doing like he's
built this great Empire and he's got
SpaceX secondarily you guys Tesla you
got SpaceX boring company there's yeah
there's a bunch of different ones but
it's like yeah maybe he's spreading
himself too thin you know why don't you
focus on now granted it's your life do
whatever you want with your life he just
stepped down from Twitter right yeah so
hopefully he's getting back on track
yeah yeah